il ya cinq ans jour pour jour la france
apprenait le martyre des sept moines de
tibéhirine enlevés et assassinés dans la
région de médéa
cinq ans après la lumière se fait peu à
peu sur les conditions de leur
disparition
en fait c'est une lutte d'influencé
entre deux différents groupes islamiques
armés qui auraient provoqué le drame
notre envoyé spécial faouzia fait qui
rit a rencontré le chef de l'ing ces
deux groupes l'hiver dernier à quelques
kilomètres du monastère désormais dr ali
benhadjar est le chef d'un groupe
dissident du gia il retrace ce parcours
des sept moines trappistes massacré ya
cinq ans à 100 km d'alger dans se trouve
juste sous le brouillard
c'est d'ici qu'il les ont emmenés vers
le refuge
et c'est là bas qu'ils les ont tués au
ne nous ont laissé leur tête sur la
route nationale voix près de médéa
les sept moines vivaient dans ce
monastère enlevé le 27 mars 96 ils ont
été exécutés 56 jours plus tard le 21
mai 96 un massacre revendiqué dans ce
communiqué signé par le chef du gia
djamel zitouni
d'après ali benhadjar lui-même
extrémistes cet acte sanglant a provoqué
la rupture avec zitouni zitouni et son
groupe compte attaquer tout ce qui
bougeait y compris les moines trappistes
pourtant nos premiers chefs avaient
conclu il y à bien longtemps un pacte de
confiance avec ces religieux on appelle
cela le hamman canada am un impact qui
consiste à ne pas toucher aux moines
en échange de soins médicaux aux
combattants blessés rené guitton vient
de publier un livre sur le martyre des
moines de tibhirine
pour l'écrivain ils étaient devenus les
otages d'une lutte fratricide zitouni
essayé d'organiser son pouvoir face à
l'hégémonique et à défier et a ordonné à
belhadj hard enlevé les moines
sauf que bien des gens ne voulais pas
qu'elles sont là c'est devenu un enjeu
de pouvoir entre ces deux groupes
et lorsque ben el hadj a refusé de les
enlever et bien itunes il aurait exécuté
par ses propres zones cet enlèvement
et le 21 mai 96 les sept moines se
retrouvé décapité
alors dans le maquis le groupe d' ali
benhadjar décide de régler le problème
et unis de façon radicale ces munitions
avec le fusil mitrailleur ont été
récupérés au cours d'une embuscade que
nous avons dressé à djamel zitouni le 16
juillet 96 on l'a tué avec deux de ses
lieutenants
ceci est donc le butin ramené par les
combattants ont mené cette embuscade
contre le gia et dieu nous a aidé à
battre djamel zitouni la tête du gia
nous en sommes enfin débarrassé à paris
un général français fut lui aussi
satisfait de cette exécution à ses yeux
justice était faite
présent au quai d'orsay durant la
gestion de la crise cet homme avait pu
mesurer toute l'incompétence des
autorités françaises et à libérer les
otages
navré par une telle inertie le militaire
avait même proposé de prendre la place
des sept moines aujourd'hui ce sont les
hommes les plus dures du gia qui
contrôle cette zone
la population a fui malgré deux
tentatives aucun moine n'est jamais
revenue vivre dans le monastère de
tibhirine désormais désert